En este video vamos a hablar de la parábola como
el lugar geométrico. Hablaremos de sus elementos
como el foco, la directriz, la distancia focal
y el eje de simetría; así que empecemos. Antes
de hablar de la idea de una parábola, sería bueno
establecer qué es un lugar geométrico. Así que,
¿qué es un lugar geométrico? Bueno, cuando
hablamos del lugar geométrico hablamos del
conjunto de los puntos en el plano que satisfacen
una determinada propiedad. Por ejemplo,
la recta es el lugar geométrico de todos los
puntos tales que, si calculamos el valor de la
pendiente para cualesquiera dos puntos en ella,
este valor es constante. O, por ejemplo, una
circunferencia se define como el valor geométrico
de todos los puntos que son equidistantes a otro
punto. Entonces, hablamos de un lugar geométrico
si encontramos en el plano puntos que satisfacen
ciertas condiciones. Ahora bien, pensemos en
esto: imagina la trayectoria de un balón que
sale de las manos de un basquetbolista hacia el
arco de anotación, o pensemos en la trayectoria
que sigue el balón de fútbol al ser pateado en
un tiro libre y que pasa por encima de la barrera
para anotar gol. ¿Qué tienen en común estas dos
trayectorias? Bueno, ambas trayectorias dibujan
un arco de parábola, pero ¿qué es una parábola?
Una parábola se define como el lugar geométrico
de los puntos de un plano que tienen equidistancia
respecto a un punto fijo y una recta, es decir,
la distancia de este punto -llamado foco- a la
parábola es la misma que la distancia de esta
recta -llamada directriz- a la parábola; esta otra
distancia del foco a la parábola es la misma que
la distancia de la directriz a la parábola;
pasa lo mismo para esta otra distancia, esta
otra distancia del foco a la parábola es la misma
que esta distancia de la directriz a la parábola.
Y las parábolas tienen un montón de aplicaciones:
se usan en los faros de los automóviles, en las
antenas parabólicas para tener una mejor recepción
en tu televisión, se utilizan en los satélites
que envían información a la Tierra, en estufas
solares, e incluso hay puentes colgantes donde los
cables adoptan esta forma para que la carga quede
distribuida de manera uniforme. Así que veamos
con calma los elementos de una parábola. Primero,
hablemos del foco. El foco es un punto fijo que no
pertenece a la parábola y se encuentra al interior
de la misma. Recuerda: la distancia de la parábola
al foco es siempre la misma que la distancia de
la parábola a la directriz. Así que el siguiente
elemento del que hablaremos es la directriz,
la cual es una recta que no toca la parábola;
ésta es la única recta que tiene la propiedad que
la distancia que la separa de cualquier punto de
la parábola será la misma que la distancia entre
el mismo punto y el foco. Llamamos eje focal a la
recta perpendicular a la directriz que pasa por el
foco. También, toda parábola tiene un vértice que
es el único punto de la parábola por el que pasa
el eje focal; éste será el punto medio entre el
foco y la directriz. Llamamos distancia focal a la
distancia que existe entre el foco y el vértice o
entre el vértice y la directriz; a esta distancia
se le suele llamar parámetro y se le denota con la
letra p. Las parábolas que estudiaremos en esta
ocasión pueden ser horizontales o verticales. Se
llaman parábolas verticales u horizontales según
la orientación de su eje focal. Las parábolas
verticales pueden abrir hacia arriba, y tienen
la forma (x-h)² = 4p que multiplica a (y-k),
donde p es la distancia focal y h, k son las
coordenadas del vértice. Las parábolas verticales
también pueden abrir hacia abajo, en cuyo caso
su ecuación canónica sería (x-h)² = -4p que
multiplica a (y-k), donde p es la distancia focal
y h, k son las coordenadas del vértice. Observa
que aquí cambió el signo de 4p, en este caso es
negativo. También tenemos parábolas horizontales,
las cuales pueden abrir hacia la derecha, cuya
ecuación sería (y-k)² = 4p que multiplica a (x-h),
donde p es la distancia focal y h, k son las
coordenadas del vértice. Observa que aquí
cambiamos de variable: la variable y es la que
se eleva al cuadrado y el signo 4p es positivo.
Por último, pero no por eso menos importante,
tenemos parábolas horizontales que abren hacia
la izquierda, cuya ecuación sería (y-k), todo
esto elevado al cuadrado, es igual a -4p que
multiplica a (x- h). De nuevo, p es la distancia
focal y h, k son las coordenadas del vértice;
la variable y se eleva al cuadrado y el signo
de 4p es negativo. Como puedes darte cuenta,
las parábolas están muy asociadas con funciones
cuadráticas. En la parábola tradicional,
tenemos que (x-h), todo esto elevado al cuadrado,
es igual a 4p que multiplica a (y-k), es decir:
(x-h) está elevado al cuadrado, lo que nos dará
una función de segundo grado. Si simplificamos,
llegaríamos a algo de la forma y = ax² + bx +
c, donde a, b y c son constantes. En este caso,
tenemos una función cuadrática, donde la
variable independiente es x, por lo tanto, es
importante mencionar que toda función cuadrática
se representa con una parábola. Sin embargo, no
toda parábola es una función. Recordemos que una
función es una correlación entre dos conjuntos,
en donde a cada elemento del dominio, es decir,
de la variable independiente, le corresponde uno
y sólo un elemento del rango, es decir, de la
variable dependiente. Pensemos ahora qué pasa
con los dos tipos de parábolas horizontales.
Puedes observar que este tipo de parábolas
no son funciones, ya que para algún elemento del
dominio, es decir, de la variable independiente x,
existen dos elementos del rango: este y este, es
decir, de la variable dependiente y; pasa lo mismo
para este otro valor, y para este, y para este.
Entonces, las parábolas verticales son gráficas de
funciones cuadráticas, mientras que las parábolas
horizontales no son gráficas de ninguna función.
Esto es todo en este primer video de introducción
a las parábolas. Ahora sabemos que una parábola
es el lugar geométrico de todos los puntos cuyas
distancias, a un punto fijo llamado foco y a una
recta llamada directriz, son iguales. Vimos
algunos ejemplos y conocimos los elementos o
partes. Además, vimos las primeras expresiones
para algunas parábolas, y hablamos de parábolas
verticales y horizontales. Además, ya sabemos
cuándo una parábola es función y cuándo no lo
es. Así que nos vemos en el siguiente video,
donde aprenderemos más sobre las parábolas.